hello and welcome back to the Shiki
science show in this video we'll look at
do your genes determine if you're a
morning person now make your YouTube
video on why waking up at 5:00 a.m.
has all these positive benefits for you
and I'm guaranteed to get some fuse but
why is it that some of us really
struggled to wake up at these early
waking routines but I didn't lee worked
for everyone so we all have different
parentheses to fall asleep at a
particular time within the 24-hour day
and since we all well should try to
sleep around seven to nine hours this
will heavily dictate when we would
actually wake up how our propensity is
to sleep a line of the day is referred
to as our corner type so there are three
key factors that influence your
chronotype age genetics and lights and
gender kind of comes under genetics and
say our Karuna types will naturally
change the age but why and what genes
are influencing our Crona types whilst
Crona types happen well describes much
less is known about the genetic
mechanisms underpinning them as
circadian disruption such as fear shift
work is associated with increased risk
of cancer type 2 diabetes and depression
understanding what influences our clock
may uncover strategies to better adjust
and manage them to suit the different
lifestyles of the modern world
so this video will look how recent
nature paper by James a towel and it
identified some genes for a large scale
genome wide Association study and helped
us to have a close understanding of the
molecular basis of Crona types so in the
study James's group compiled data from
previous genome-wide Association studies
where participants had self-identified
their chronotype so the team identified
327 novel osai associated with the
morning chronotype now bringing the
total up to 351 different news I so just
to briefly recap on what genome-wide
Association studies are they are
effectively um mechanisms identified
gene loci associated with the trades so
in this case this rate would be a
morning person and to identify the
sigh genetic variants such as single
nucleotide polymorphisms are analyzed to
see if certain variants appear more
frequently in people with the trait than
expected the beauty of genome-wide
Association studies that they are
hypothesis free but the key word to
highlights is Association Association of
beliefs I over the trade doesn't mean
causation but at nonetheless identifies
a site that could be further studied so
when you look at the correlation of
differently side with the trades in this
case chronotype you will find that some
have a higher correlation than others
they're more significant and so we can
display this data and whatever fair to
us my heart implodes and this allows you
to identify a site where there seems to
be a strong correlation why there are
likely to be genes while there are
certain single nucleotide polymorphisms
that might predispose an individual so
we're having that phenotype in this case
being a morning person so in the
Manhattan plot from james's paper they
found that strongly associated gene loci
while within the core clock genes such
as the three period genes and
cryptochrome one and so I've briefly
introduced these proteins before and so
I'll put a link to that video in the
description and so in addition to the
enrichment for the circadian rhythm
genes which are kind of somewhat
expected
there were also genes involved in brain
development and neurogenesis that were
also strongly associated in addition
tissues enriched with these genes
included all types of brain tissue and
retinal tissue and so since light is a
strong site Gaber
of the circadian rhythm and light is
detected by retinal cells there's tissue
enrichment and the genes identified all
seem very plausible interestingly
another gene identified was FTO or fats
mass and obesity related transcripts now
this gene also came up in their
genome-wide Association study looking at
the link between genetic traits and
obesity and I spoke about that in a
previous video see the link in the
description and so this protein is
involved in appetite regulation and so
since food also implicates into
of the circadian rhythm it seems such an
ethic variants that alter the timing of
clock modulation subsequently influence
chronotype nonetheless to determine if
any of these gene enrichments are
actually causal for chronotype
individual in-depth analyses for each of
these genes will be required but if
chronotype has a genetic underpinning
why does it change of age so firstly
let's look at how chronotype varies of
age
so this graph reflects data collected so
far
that shows that chronotype gets later
during adolescence and then advances
back to being earlier again after
entering the twenties so just like why
different cell types with the same DNA
are different
which genes are expressed by how much
and when and when they are expressed
will also vary depending on age and
gender so it is currently thought that
the onset of puberty is predominantly
responsible for the change towards
evening nurse and adolescence hormonal
differences such as testosterone I
thought to explain the gender difference
in seen male students with high
testosterone levels are positively
correlated with evening this and soon
results like these are urging many to
argue for later school start times and
so these differences will again become
clearer once the general mechanisms of
chronotype are further explored so just
for a bit of fun were my circadian
rhythm be ok may not be on the top of
your list of questions if you were
suddenly going to move to Mars but since
a Mars day is 37 minutes longer than an
Earth Day this could really mess up your
circadian rhythm so although being a
morning person may have alternative
benefits those who've later chrono types
may actually be better suited to living
on Mars fancy that a but how can you
workouts if you're a lark or now a
morning or an evening person so without
doing any genetic testing age is a good
indicator to use but otherwise you are
do you feel sluggish when you wake
before sex always your best work and
evening whilst prototype reference may
seem trivial it can have a huge impact
on your life and risk of metabolic
diseases and while suggesting
your walk school schedule to see your
Cronus I may be out of your hands
appreciating and embracing your own type
is the best thing that you can do to
keep your circadian rhythm most optimal
and to avoid the seasons that are
associated with circadian disruption so
hopefully this video has given you an
insights into how different genes and
genetic Clarion's can influence your own
attire